good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast
it is Wednesday Claudia's favorite day
of the week shall I get away yes it is
welcome back to the show everyone how's
everyone doing and by everyone I mean
Claudia how you dome hey Jax hey
everyone happy Wednesday hope everyone's
feeling sprightly and bubbly I for one
am NOT but for the sake of pretending
let's pretend what a great day okay so I
did something again um where I woke up
early to workout and if I ever have this
idea again please stop me like my
workout we just trashed my output was
trash because I had no energy in the
morning like i legit couldn't move my
legs any faster my output if your
appellate Oh sir then you know what this
means like compared to my last PR on a
30-minute ride I was like 50 kgs less
like the same output I did the first day
that I got the bike I'm like regressing
so I need to stop working out in the
morning I always feel like it's gonna
make me feel better and it just made me
feel like a worthless loser so that's
why I have a wet hair but I'm really
like liking my man vibe today what do
you think why it's not worth it to work
out in the morning not that I work out
ever but it's like quarantine days are
so long like it's already hard to fill
things up and working out is one of the
things you do after the toast so your
waking up early you're giving yourself
more hours in the day to fill up with
stuff and you're getting your workout
out of the way so it's like something
that you would do after the toast like
now you have this free time that like
you don't really need yeah but like I
still dread it so I am glad that it's
out of the way like I would rather sit
on my ass and you and be borned and like
get dressed and work out so I'm glad
it's out of the way but it wasn't as
good of a workout as it could have been
um and I know that people are so gung-ho
about working out in the mornings but
where do you get that energy from what a
girl no I think people are gonna go and
once again I can't really speak to the
validity of this thing is how I've never
worked out morning noon or night but I
think people are going on working out in
the morning when they have full lives
not when like the day is theirs yes that
is interesante
okay that's a good point I also did the
lose oh right I gave myself every chance
for it to be fabulous and I was just
nothing of the sort
so I'm sorry Here I am though and I'm
like now
got a showered and I did a fresh watch
and I do feel good sitting here right
now so maybe in the end it was worth it
you feel good sitting right here okay we
need to talk because I gave you I gave
you an assignment to watch the High
School Musical trilogy with an open mind
and an open heart and I need to know
your thoughts you also gave me this meet
me an assignment to read Jessica
Simpson's book which I did not but I
watched two out of three of the High
School Musical movies I will be watching
the third because you say it's like one
of the better ones and I enjoyed it
because like it was something to do the
first movie is like should we wait on TV
recap or just dive in just dive in the
the first movie is so cringy it is like
a bad hallmark Disney like fusion um but
it's good and it's cute and the dancing
in the choreography and the high school
is so cute but to me the most shocking
moment was like when the movie ended and
there was no musical I don't know why I
remember like there being a musical or
it's just because it's called high
school musical but the whole movie and
all like the status-quo being disrupted
is about a callback yeah that's that's
what's so crazy like there's so much
power in a callback and while I agree
with you that the first movies like
cringy ish hallmark I like it was a
decom it wasn't meant to take over the
world like they put out this movie like
they put out a million other Disney
movies when we were kids and people just
really like just loved it so then they
built on it and obviously the second
movie has a much higher production value
but the first like the bones of the
first movie are good and the heart and
of the the first movie is good but I
like seeing everyone's glow ups in the
second movie like some of them got
fillers like Ashley Tisdale definitely
got her lips done her her side bangs
were like my eighth grade aesthetic like
I liked that they all got spray tans um
Vanessa Anne cut her hair she was going
like she was trying out a lob it was it
was interesting I want to hear your
thoughts on the second movie because
back in the day we really felt like the
slum of the sophomore slump but watching
it now
like I have so much respect for it ya
know I they think it was slumpy vibes at
all I thought the soundtrack was
fabulous all for one and one for all
like that was literally dancing in front
of my TV like a child I thought the
soundtrack was really good um it was
frustrating for me because like I had a
problem with like the ethics of the show
like I just didn't really feel like Zac
Efron like wanting to better in his
future and not taking Zeke and Chad to
the Albuquerque gym like made him a bad
person it's like no he's putting his
future first not his job at the Country
Club for the summer yeah I feel like
justice for him so where do you land on
now the justice for Sharpay campaign cuz
after I watched these movies I didn't
feel the same way well it's a little
annoying because at the end of the first
movie when she didn't get the role and
they're all dancing in the gym she's
like one of them and she's like whatever
I'll be your understudy like she was it
was it was like the villain role had
peaked and now she was just one of them
but then you transition to the summer
and she's like reverted back to her
villainous ways which I was then ever
and I thought it was inconsistent when
like I thought we had come full circle
after the first movie and yes her
behavior in the second movie was
abhorrent like just on like a human
level the way she spoke to staff and
like even that song fabulous which I
loved sick you go do I'm like are you
[ __ ] kidding me like those are adults
like you can't talk to them even the way
she spoke to mr. Fulton who is a
fabulous actor yeah mr. Fulton in the
second movie is supposed to fill the
hole of miss darbus because they're not
in school you know and miss darbus is
really the heart and soul of the first
movie when you watch it back it's
justice for miss darbus like she is a
queen like her talents are wasted on the
East High Wildcats completely unlike her
vibe and like the way she speaks is like
literally what I want to be when I grow
up like when she's good she's watching
all the auditions and like nobody can
sing and these two kids do like an
interpretive dance to breaking free and
she was like that was and she tries to
say something nice she goes very
disturbing please go so iconic and I
agreed like when you're a kid obviously
like you just think of the teacher I was
like the annoying character but now that
I'm an adult and I have respect for
teachers I'm like mr. Burris was just
trying to do her [ __ ] job
there was just so many inconsistencies
in the movie like the period that they
had with miss darbus
I thought in the beginning of the movie
in his homeroom because it was they sat
down she said two words and then it was
15 minutes and it was gone then it's
like at the summer movie it's the last
period so how can it be homeroom and
it's like then she's been she's diving
into history at one point and I'm like
what teacher are you so you're the drama
teacher homeroom teacher English and
history teacher get you a teacher who
could do it all I guess yeah and by the
way in high school more so in the middle
school but like I guess it's really
middle school like we would have one
teacher and she taught us every subject
I guess that that's actually true I'm
wearing like rotating classes yet that's
true but it was high school okay well
maybe like they had a different sort of
curriculum in East High maybe um
in terms of characters I do have to say
I don't feel in the first movie that
Zack and Vanessa like really deserved
that role like they were laid to both
auditions and like they had to be like
coerced into doing it and then she
finally after miss darbus says you're
late sorry I won't let you perform she
lets them perform and Gabriela doesn't
sing the music starts and she gets
scared it's like that's obviously not
what you want in a star like of course
I'm looking through the movie like the
lens of like I want to support Terrain
Gabriela but like they didn't really
deserve the role as a thespian myself I
wouldn't agree with the casting yeah
well I think it was a combination of a
few things like I think miss darbus was
fed the [ __ ] up with Sharpay and Ryan
and like them botching all of these
songs and making them like trash also
she did say she said if you're not gonna
put the theater first like let's she she
agreed with Sharpay to move the audition
to the same time as their other
priorities and let's see if they make
the theater a priority and you know what
they did they like they went ham they
blew up the science lab they caused a
blackout they got the whole school there
everyone's jamming with Troy Gabriella
and they really had talent or should I
say Drew Seeley because you know that
Zac Efron doesn't sing in the first
movie yes and I was hearing Drew Seeley
like so hard because he was in another
Cinderella story dancing around with
Selena Gomez right
such a good movie such a good movie and
I heard his voice the whole time but as
a kid I didn't know I really thought it
was true but like there was just well
you kind of got into my head a little
bit like when it came to how I felt
about certain characters like Chad was
the worst he was such a bad friend in
the way that he was just like making fun
of Zeke his friend for wanting to bake
creme brulees like who wants like a
judgmental friend like that and that's
like with every song he sings like you
think he was getting more into it but
then at the crunch
he was like I don't dance you were
dancing in the gym to get your head in
the game so why are you lying yeah yeah
no he was just like so um regressive you
know he just like couldn't help his
friends like break out of their shells
he just wanted and he like he was the
status quo yes and he was I felt like
the character who was keeping the status
quo in the entire school yes and
honestly in the first movie him until
like the status quo is kind of the
villain you know cuz it's really not
Sharpay she's just trying to protect her
drama club and we can understand that
it's really like Troy and I mean Chad
and Taylor are the villain sort of like
trying to keep their friends like in
these boxes but we don't live in boxes
no we refuse to live in boxes so I'm
gonna watch a third movie and I'll let
you know I just I have a lot of respect
for like the choreo and the dance
numbers like when they ended the second
movie at the pool Country Club like
singing all for one like everyone was
wearing bright colors jumping in the
pool like I was living yeah Kenny Ortega
that's the Kenny Ortega effect and he
Kenny oh problems he does a good job he
knows what he's doing
yeah it was good yeah okay well I'm
excited for you to watch HSM 3 I'm
excited for this journey for you um I
guess like should I save my TV recap
because I finished little fires
everywhere and I don't spoil it like I
might watch the last I'm gonna I'm gonna
spoil it so because I need cuz in order
to talk about like what's wrong with it
I need to spoil it and I know you're not
gonna watch anytime soon
just like I didn't spoil Jessica
Simpson's book for you I always said I
had while it was still fresh in my mind
so I could have talked about it okay
yeah I'm not gonna finish it I really
thought it was terrible it was so
terrible and I'll see before the TV
recap segment because maybe some people
like don't give a [ __ ] and just want to
hear the past five yeah maybe
okay so I guess it's time without
further ado to get into the Fast Five
story is that you need to know before
you wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast
and that's true Jackie but if I may a
word from our sponsors today's episode
is brought to you by centered sometimes
adding one final piece brings the whole
ensemble together and that finishing
touch cue to your perfume fragrances can
create lasting impressions because smell
is so closely linked with memories if
you're ready to make a lasting
impression Sanford can help you discover
your signature scent or keep things
fresh with new fragrances from brands
like Dolce & Gabbana Tom Ford Versace
and more scent bird is a monthly
perfume and cologne subscription service
with over 600 designer brands just
choose the fragrance you want to try and
they'll send you a 30 day supply in a
travel friendly refillable case to help
you find the perfect scent you could
sort their extensive collection by brand
style occasion season and more plus they
have products that go beyond fragrances
like skincare wellness and makeup from
best-selling brands like Aparri glam
glow glow recipe and tart if you want to
get 30% off your first month today
that's only ten dollars for your first
fragrance go to send bird dot-com /
steen and use our promo code steen to
get 30% off your first month that means
your first perfume of Cologne is just
$10 again that's SC ent BIR d.com /
Steen to sign up and use our promo codes
steen st een sun on smell amazing
amazing actually the SEM bird right here
a leak perfume and likes perfume is just
one of those like Warren King cheats
where you can like be a fancy [ __ ]
with minimal effort I love minimal
efforts my thing me too okay let's get
into it because we actually have some
good stories today first story the photo
heard around the world
Adele shared a photo from her birthday
yesterday on her Instagram where she
posts scarcely showing off even more
weight loss than what we had seen in the
photos from like Jake's birthday and a
few months ago when everyone was talking
about it like her Beach yeah she posted
to celebrate her 32nd birthday saying
thank you for the birthday love I hope
you're all staying safe and sane during
this crazy time she captioned the photo
of herself looking glamorous in Elle
Zynga's balloon sleeve little black
dress she really looks so fabulous I am
like she's living she looks so glamorous
and she looks so happy and I love her
there's a lot of conversation being had
here like people are obviously so like
living for her glow up and then a lot of
people are saying like is it derogatory
towards fat people to celebrate
someone's weight loss and it's like I'm
so like body-positive
and I'm like I'm happy for this [ __ ]
like I don't know I don't think you
might you would have to be both like one
or the other like I think it's great if
someone wants to lose weight great if
somebody wants to gain weight great like
why do we care yeah and I think really
if she had posted any photo from her 30
second
they like looking happy and just like
it's really how you feel is you know I
feel like we would all be celebrating it
you know but also like losing weight
like is and part of trying to lose
weight it's hard and it's an
accomplishment and it deserves to be
celebrated but that's what you're trying
to do but I don't think it takes away
from people who choose not to lose
weight totally I was like reading some
crazy comments people are heated about
it and I'm just like go girl like do
what you got to do you want to be you
want to be it's in you want to be sad
great great
I applaud you either way yeah she just
she looks so beautiful and glowing and
and that have any weight got AlphaTech
dress that's a great dress she looks
like glamorous as hell she looks like a
Spice Girl honestly yeah where's the new
music though where's the new music
though I mean there's so much going on
in her life and her divorce like her
divorce was really um he got like
seventy million dollars oh did he yeah
well she's need to put out a new album
she make it all back yeah but like I
think she literally had to split her
fortune which is just [ __ ] terrible
[ __ ] terrible um also her album her
last album I've been listening to it a
lot in the queue and like it holds up it
feels new it's so amazing it's like
honestly it really is enough right now
when ever I hear that song when we were
young I'll never not feel like sad happy
and power powerful like I [ __ ] love
that song in that music video where she
looks just so epic like that is I think
one of the best songs ever written
um I completely agree I think that's one
of the best albums ever and like make
definitely my favorite album of hers but
um it definitely I need to resurface it
you know I'm always looking for Adams to
play on repeat I need to add that to my
mental cue I'm so excited for her new
music because there's just so much going
on in her life she's a mom and now she's
single like it's just gonna be so
fabulous totally okay
next story talking about one of our
favorite people she is just like coming
for Vogue because Jessica Simpson is he
crying the body shaming by bogan Met
Gala history have you seen this story no
okay so I guess yesterday or whatever
Monday was Vogue put out like an oral
history
and I read it of the Met Gala and so
they had a bunch of different people
contributing like little blurbs on it
like you know little things that
happened or how they felt their first
Matt Goa what they used to think of the
Met Gala they had a bunch of people
including like Kendall Jenner Naomi
Campbell else Anning a bunch of people
who work for Vogue including one woman
Sally singer who used to work for Vogue
and she in her oral history she said
that she recalled when Jessica Simpson
quote her breasts maybe fell out of her
dress on the red carpet and then at
dinner it was suddenly like whoa Jessica
Simpson's breasts are across from me at
a dinner table and they are on a platter
and I'm looking at them then she also
talks about how she was with John Mayer
and John Mayer was like putting his
hands on her boobs and was just like all
about Jessica Simpson's boobs this one
excerpt excuse me yeah so Jessica
Simpson posted feeling a little like
Jayne Mansfield after reading this
inaccurate oral history of the Met Ball
where I am body shamed by Sally singer
but in all seriousness I have persevered
through shaming my own body and
internalizing the world's opinions about
it for my entire adult life to read this
much-anticipated article about the
classiest fashion event there is and
have to be shamed by another woman for
having boobs in 2020 is nauseating okay
there's so many things that are weird
about this first of all the fact that
like they asked this Vogue contributor
like you went to the Met Gala what do
you remember like she she went to most
fabulous high-profile event and all she
remembers is someone's tits like that's
weird for small it was like one memory
out of a lot like it was a bunch of
little blurbs of memory so she
contributed other stories but this was
one of the stories and that Vogue
decided to publish and sure everyone
just like sent in blurbs Vogue did
apologize for including it in their
article but like no this is Evan no this
is this whole thing is weird like I
blame the girl I blame Vogue I blame
everyone I'm like literally what's the
point in running a magazine if you're
not gonna edit it like isn't that your
whole job editors at magazines like who
who the [ __ ] let this be published like
that is so condescending it's like so I
don't know I would just feel so we I
don't even know what the right word is
like if someone were just talking about
my tits so much like maybe it's because
nobody does like maybe I wouldn't mind
it but like it's like it's so it's so
wrong no but like Jessica Simpson
feel like a lot of people talk about
them because they're like so fabulous
and I feel like if you want to talk
about them it can only be in terms of
celebration because they're so wonderful
but like to talk about a woman's boobs
in a condescending way in 2020
nauseating no to talk about them at all
like another woman's boobs is weird but
if you're gonna do it negatively like
that's [ __ ] up let's just celebrate it
without their consent is still a little
weird look I mean but we do that all the
time we talk about Katy Perry's boobs at
that event with John Mayer we talk we
literally after I read open book I
googled Jessica since and Met Gala John
Mayer and we literally posted these
photos on our Instagram because like
what's amazing she looked amazing so I
think it's great to celebrate everyone's
bodies um but just like to be weird
about boobs it right now what the [ __ ]
it just it seems really losery I'm sorry
of this harvest girl it's I'm calling it
it's loser crime it's no but it's not
loser loser it's no it's a loser on
Queen crying I just feel like bad for
Jessica Simpson like I just I want
everyone to respect her yeah I don't
know why people feel like she's a
punching bag or she can just be like
spoken about in any sort of way but they
obviously didn't read open book and I
think Sally singer if she wants to make
it right needs to read her book you know
what I think we should give her an
assignment I want a book report I want a
book report and then you know what then
I'll move on then then so 7 I'm so like
proud of Jessica's in from for standing
up for herself because one I would have
never heard about this Vogue oral
history without justice Simpson speaking
out about it because she's like shedding
light on something that nobody gives a
[ __ ] about because everybody cares about
her and also I forget okay well justice
has been served I think I think so - I
think she served it up for herself like
she doesn't let anyone come for her
anymore like she is everything I love
her I love her before we get into the
next story I just want to issue a
trigger warning because we are about to
discuss sexual assault
um speaking of other people that we love
Nikki Bella reveals that she was raped
twice in high school although the Bella
sisters have come out with a new memoir
that they wrote together and Nikki is
opening up about being raped twice as a
teenager in the new memoir incomparable
incomparable incomparable I mean I'm no
literary scholar but I think the former
WWE star shares in the book co-written
by her twin sister brie but she was
first attacked at the age of 15 by a
fellow student she thought was a friend
quote my virginity was stolen from me
without my consent I was raped by a guy
I thought was a friend while I was
passed out at a party I'd had too many
beers and maybe some shots of hard
alcohol and I only woke up because my
stomach hurt
I came to and this guy was both on top
of me and inside of me and I pushed him
off and ran out of the room and then she
said that she was also raped again by a
college-age man whom she says drugged
her when she was 16 and so she lived
with all of this and she like kept it a
secret and she said she blamed herself
and started to lose her confidence quote
I started to disrespect myself and then
the relationships I got into at a young
age I let other people disrespect me and
felt like that's okay this is what I
deserved
oh my god that's horrible horrible this
is so heartbreaking but it's like so
brave of her to share this story now um
she said that the meet you moved in and
her platform is a WWE star help her come
to terms with speaking up about it what
a truck like what traumatizing expect to
experience once is horrible and awful
but like twice are you kidding me that's
so so sad I love her I love her so much
I'm really excited about this book um
I'm definitely gonna read it I love the
two of them and total bells is back on
TV now I have it all recorded but I
haven't caught like two batch that -
they have um really is like created an
empire for themselves a hundred percent
I feel like they just like work quietly
you know they're not always just like
and until you watch their show you don't
realize like how much they do and how
successful they are um and they have a
really nice life and and also I feel
like we keep forgetting they're pregnant
at the same time right now like that is
so special and they have a podcast they
do it all they do it all they're really
cute and they've really like just
created this whole thing like out of
some show total divas that was like
really
not that popular when it started but
like people really tuned in for them and
now they have their own show and I think
they're great and I'm probably not gonna
read the book but I wish them well I'll
recap it for you yeah they're you know
actually I feel like they have an engine
I don't know how you get to where you
are like in like what road in your
career do you have to take to end up
being where the Bella sisters are you
know what do you mean like WWE like
that's such an interesting background I
don't know anyone who's ever become like
a famous wrestler you know like they're
like the only for me like female
wrestlers that I know yeah well I think
it was the show total divas that like
what I mean like how do you get involved
in WWE at first cuz they were famous not
to us but they were famous before the e
show oh yeah well you audition like
anything else yeah yeah like it's a
career path like some people wanna be a
cheerleader some people want to be a
dancer some people want to be a WWE Diva
yeah but like if you're a cheerleader
like you join the squad
you audition and you join you would like
tryout for WWE no I think you know
probably it's like getting some training
program oh you know what I actually saw
the movie fighting with my family and
there is um it's about page from WWE and
there's a training program that she
joins to be a diva and you know it's
like weeks it's kind of like DCC making
the team like you eat they weed out
people who don't make the cut and
eventually they have some divas on their
hands hmm maybe that's what I should
have done with my life maybe it is
Bobbie swim okay
next story is about your favorite person
Miley Cyrus I have some news for you
that I don't think you're gonna like
because she didn't interview with The
Wall Street Journal oh she did I didn't
see it everywhere you did where'd you
see it oh my god
literally everywhere oh my god well I
saw it up pop craving news and they they
clip some of the highlights that I just
want to share her because she is
discussing a possible future as a full
time talk-show host
so the interviewer asked you told Jimmy
Fallon you don't do anything halfway so
when you decided to do this you went
all the way do you want to be a full
time TV host one day she said I love
connecting with people there's something
about when you listen to someone else's
stories that you realize all these
pieces of yourself - I think that's what
I've missed in my life those
relationships I also love entertainment
encouraging people to celebrate their
uniqueness a lot of what I've
represented in my entire career is
individuality and gender identity and
sexual identity so yeah I would love to
create a platform where individuality is
highlighted and a place for good news
and light and activism and optimism and
highlighting the folks doing really big
work who don't always get the attention
that is deserved I think there's a world
where I could do it all and have it all
okay honestly as a platform that sounds
really nice honestly like good news
activism I'm here for it and I just hope
that if there are people in the world
who want Miley Cyrus as a talk show I
was like I hope that they get what they
want for them that's what I'll say I
totally agree you know this actually
reminds me of something I heard
yesterday which was that Selena Gomez is
getting a cooking show on HBO max which
is like quarantine cooking show oh my
god okay wait I meant to I meant to have
that as a story because um I saw that we
posted it to the morning toast that
where she is hosting an executive
producing an ad home quarantine cooking
show so isn't that a vlog like she's you
know he's pressing record she's pressing
record she's talking to the camera and
she's executive producing it like she's
emailing it to HBO max like are you like
okay I host an executive produce like so
much it's crazy I didn't know that that
was the term for what I was doing yeah I
mean I'm less concerned with that and
just more concerned it's like how is
anyone supposed to ever like make it as
a chef or a talk-show host if
celebrities just like keep deciding that
like they have no background but I want
to become an Tonight Show host you know
like how are people ever supposed to get
those jobs who just start from the
ground up if you know the next I know
garden is just Selena Gomez go to the
Hamptons right just Selena Gomez like in
quarantine making I don't know what
we're all cooking in quarantine by the
way when is this show premiering in
August the last thing I want to do is
watch someone else in quarantine when
I'm trying to get back to normal life
you know I have full plans in August I
don't intend on like watching content
that reminds me of the queue
I thought that was a crazy I mean I
guess it's for HBO Mac so it's like it's
not taking up cable time they'll put
anything on there you know and she is
literally the most famous person in the
world so if we can get like half of the
Selena stands watching HBO max they're
gonna do it I understand that decision
for them but it's like it's low-hanging
fruit yeah and I'm just like sad
thinking about all the Instagram chefs
who think one day like I'll get a show
on HBO
no actually I'm sorry you won't yeah I
don't really know any Instagram chefs
but you know what I didn't loving
tick-tock chefs I am always like saving
recipes that I obviously never make um
from some chefs on tick-tock like they
really like all of those short little
videos where they're just like throwing
things in and they're like you know
there's a few really good ones I don't
know their names but do you know Tabitha
I think so did she the one that cooks
with the spices like so like that cuz
it's your business yes that's a little
funny yeah she's great
and I really like I I think I've made
some stops he talked you know how have
you seen the like egg grilled cheese
sort of one um where you put the omelet
with the bread and then you flip it over
and it's just a sandwich yeah
like that's pretty cool there's some
cool I'm happening I made a grilled
cheese yesterday and um in the pan I
like really made it nice it's like smart
butter bread and it was so good like
literally decadent as [ __ ] that's what
I've been making every day but yesterday
my avocados had ripened so I made an
avocado toast and it was so good I
immediately got up and made another one
oh that's so good you know sandwiches
are good but they're relatively small
I feel like unless they're having like a
BLT with dirt like a million things
yeah PBM subway yeah but like a PB&J or
a grilled cheese like to me is much more
of a snack than it is a meal
I kind of agree like I used to think a
sandwich was like a big meal but it's
it's not that much no it's definitely
you need like chips to go along with it
you definitely need some side dishes
also it depends on your bread like the
square footage you get on your bread can
really make an impact into the size of
your sandwich and add the bread that I
was using which is very good Sara Lee
holy they're they're small slices so
really felt like more of you know an
appetizer than an entree
I've started using a zekiel bread that
snitch uses because I'm just like I
should save calories where I can and
it's actually really good and I don't
even taste a difference but last night I
made meatless Bolognese with chickpea
pasta
I actually made three different kinds of
pastas because I'm just making the
chickpea pasta for the Bolognese because
I was like I'll try and be healthy then
I was like what if it's gross I wasted
all this bouillon days so I made regular
pasta and I had all this extra regular
caustics I was making so much pasta that
I made half of the regular pasta into
pesto pasta for my husband so in three
different kinds of processes and I ate
so much of the chickpea pasta and it was
just like not good compared to pasta and
it's like if you're gonna eat pasta go
all the way like if I'm gonna be healthy
I'll have a salad but I'm not eating
healthy pasta like it was I it also made
me like so full because there was so
much fiber I just felt like kind of
gross all night I was like did I eat too
much maybe I shouldn't just eating
regular would have known what I was
doing it was confusing yeah I have never
obviously had chickpea pasta once again
I'm just speaking from a lack of
experience but I can't imagine that it
would be good yeah it's just like if
you're in the mood for pasta it's just
not pasta so go all the way or don't
yeah we're like have a salad I'm just in
life I'm all or nothing that's just my
motto for everything I I think everyone
knows that about me by now
um so chickpea pasta just doesn't fit
into that equation yeah I'm sorry that
that happened to you it's okay it was a
learning lesson you know that's what
life's about Jackie
learning ok our fifth and final story is
really sweet because Vanessa Bryant has
shared a letter from Kobe Bryant on her
birthday Vanessa Bryant was able to open
one last letter from Kobe on her
birthday revealing she waited until her
special day to read an unopened envelope
from her late husband she said yesterday
I found an envelope labeled to the love
of my life from to poppy she said I
waited to open one more letter on my
birthday it gave me something to look
forward to today that is like a book to
find an unopened letter
you know big time wow that's really
sweet oh my god I mean I just can't like
talk about these two because it's like
my worst fears and I feel so sad and I
just like love her and
I'm glad that she got like a little gift
on her birthday um it reminds me it's so
actually no it's not even remotely
similar but regardless I think that um
this is lovely and I like how she
publicly deals with her grief I feel
like a lot of people are like more
introverted about it like don't share
people in the public eye and then also
just like regular human beings yeah so I
just think she's so brave I agree I feel
like it's something that when you see
someone else going through it it just
makes you feel less alone and motile I
think she's a wonderful woman
the past five stories honestly there
were all five stories about wonderful
women no they were five stories and they
were fast oh they were definitely fast
but have no fear our show is not even
close to over because Jackie's gonna
recap her TV from last night and then
we're gonna dive into your toasters
which is our Dyson air pump rules recap
that's what we have to do first I know
let's just let's just hit it okay so
this is my thoughts on the episode like
it was an episode where nothing major
happened making me realize like this is
now the show like when they went to that
beach cleanup I could not believe that
Stassi and Bo where they're like
supporting Max's beach cleanup it's like
they're really trying to each in the
world that was so funny they're really
trying to like integrate the cast and I
guess this is just how it is we're not
even gonna like try like if I just
couldn't believe that Stassi and beau
were there I really I could understand
like Katie and Tom because Tom works
with Max but um it was it was
interesting and I didn't mind it at all
um I wish we got like more of the beach
looks because I was absolutely loving
Lolich hem so look and I just needed
more of it um as well as Dana's and I
guess the two big things in the episode
were Sheena
um and her music video and I was
released I watched the music video
because she of course she posted her
Instagram like watch what you didn't see
because we kept seeing like the same
highlights and zooming in on Brett's
face like I was freaking out like that
was the craziest thing I ever saw
why would you it's just weird like that
she would use like a friend and someone
that she had a crowd like obviously she
was using it to like get close to him
and for maybe like make him realize that
he's
with her and she'll give him a [ __ ]
and like he'll just want to be with her
forever transparent
she's so transparent it's crazy but also
like Dana is her friend and Dana's
hooking up with him like it was so wrong
on so many accounts like I was
uncomfortable watching it I can't even
imagine being there and she wasn't even
paying him it was like it was so weird
and then I'm so glad that when he said
to her like I was uncomfortable that she
like legit understood and was like I'm
so embarrassed I feel weird am I good
because we all [ __ ] feel weird yeah I
just think scheana sometimes like
forgets who she is you know and and to
me like the most interesting part of the
episode but I could have watched a whole
episode on wasn't a love triangle
because like I love Dana I love that
everyone like wants her and that like
she now has options and I hate that
whole maxing like I was scared it's like
come on this is 2020 we don't even say
that anymore like I can't deal with
stuff like that
and I hope that she doesn't go back to
max um and I love her like everyone's so
invested in it like Stassi at the beach
was like I heard you're in a love
triangle like it really is the most
interesting thing going on in the group
and in the show and you I thought about
sites episode was gonna be better than
it was because there were so many events
they had Kristen sting they had the
beach thing that had Tom and Ariana's
dinner party like I thought there would
just be more momentum because usually
it's like one birthday party a week but
there was three this week and it was
just like nothing sauce yeah another big
thing is like Jackson his temper that
was really [ __ ] weird and crazy um
and then this stuff was like Kristen it
makes me realize there's so much that we
don't know because that was just
something offhanded that he said just to
prove that she's a liar um that she had
sex with someone two weeks ago and she
was saying it's four weeks ago and she's
with Carter like it's weird yeah but
it's like at this point the show is
becoming confusing because there's so
much that we don't know like with the
Katie Kristen and Stassi drama um I
didn't listen but apparently Stassi had
Katie on her podcast where they gave so
much context to as to why their
friendship with Kristen is being um
coming to an end and and now it's like
with this Kristen stuff in Jax it's like
I don't even know what they were talking
about literally I was so confused and
they're the producers are just making us
do so much like physical labor to figure
out what's going on the show is not
laying it out for us anymore
and I'm just confused I honestly didn't
know what was going on at Kristen's
t-shirt thing like the whole time yeah
and it's like it's weird and it's also
all these people who don't like each
other but are just like kind of
pretending to like even Tom and Jax like
they go sneakers cleaning together and
then in their interviews like they're
talking [ __ ] about each other so it's
like why am i watching them clean their
sneakers together yeah everyone was like
humming for Jax but you know I'm a Jax
apologist and I just like really liked
him I felt really bad for Brittney like
I just feel like Brittney takes a lot um
and she like kind of reached her
breaking point um last night and I felt
really bad for her yeah I felt really
bad for her and I thought Jax was like
totally out of line
but I just didn't get it maybe that's
the point it's like it was just coming
out of nowhere but he seemed like he was
on about something and we just weren't
getting in yeah and then he was like
saying how he's having going through
some struggles what he was trying to say
is like his mental health is like not at
its best but he was like I'm having
mental problems and it was like I wanted
to feel for him but then like the way he
speaks so derogatory about like Ariana
and her journey with depression I was
like this these two are not equal like
he was you can't you can't want sympathy
from people and then be like a dick to
someone else who's going through the
same thing yeah I totally agree that's
how I felt also so it was a fine episode
yeah it was fine
um okay little fires everywhere so I
finished it and I just want to say like
the show is really really bad and I
thought the book was bad and then the
show was even worse because they make
all of the characters even more
unlikable like they made Mia so much
more unlikable they made Elena so much
more unlikable they did all these things
in the show that didn't happen in the
book and it's like there was enough
going on in the book that we could have
like you just added like all of these
different crazy things and it just
wasn't necessary and now at the end of
the book and at the end of the show the
house burns down and in the book it is
spoiler alert it is Izzy who burns the
house down and she really you get it
she's just [ __ ] done with these
people she's done with this house she's
done with this life in the show um also
like Elena becomes some so much of a
worst character in the show because she
like doesn't like is he she never wanted
her she never wanted to be her mother
she doesn't enjoy being her mother and
book it's not like that like she really
feels like so protective over is he
because like she grew up like she was um
like a difficult baby and a difficult
pregnancy and she just always had to be
like no is he no is he no and now her
whole life she's just like is he no um
and all is he hears is no but in the
show they made it like where Elena says
- is he like I didn't want you and easy
runs away which she does in the book
anyway and then the other three kids
burn down the house in the show yeah so
but like the other three kids yet
they're going through a rough patch as a
family but you don't burn down your
[ __ ] house over that no that makes no
sense and you know what I understand
like when TVs or movie shows adapt from
books and things get changed but like to
me to change like the biggest thing it
was like it's a murder mystery and then
you change a who actually murdered the
person like to me that just seems so
weird yeah it was just weird they added
all of these different elements like
Elaine all these problems between Elena
and Joshua Jackson and that did not
exist in the book at all and it's
frustrating because like they made Elena
into this monster and yes she's not a
great person by the end of the book but
she's not like philandering and cheating
on her husband and she didn't cheat on
him 15 years ago she never like walked
out and went to a bar met someone else
and she didn't do that in New York City
either so like there was already so much
to unpack even like in the show Brian
and Lexi breakup
mmm and like Lexi is so upset about it
and that didn't happen in the book I'm
pretty sure what about the baby oh so
this is what happens in the book and in
the show the court case happens the
judge rules that the baby belongs with
the McCullough's not Liberty parents not
the not BB child then like that night or
the next night BT ciao while everyone is
sleeping goes to the house takes the
baby and gets on a plane to China and
they the McAuliffe's like spend some
time looking for her but they know that
they never will find her um but in the
show they kind of botched that storyline
too because they had like and what Linda
McCullough realized in the book was like
she woke up the next morning and the
baby was gone but she realized that the
baby did not cry
when bebe took her you know cuz I
thought is her mother in the book they
[ __ ] Bachchan Linda's trying to fall
asleep the baby monitor goes off with a
little crying the husband's like don't
worry we're safe don't like doesn't let
her go and check and then later in the
middle of the night she goes to check on
the baby and the baby's gone and bebe
ghosts like Niagara Falls but that just
makes it seem like oh they're gonna look
for the baby now whereas in the book it
is so final that they are never gonna
find this baby and that baby and the
baby are in China see like to me that
whole storyline with the birth mother
was more interesting than like the fire
and and is he like I didn't [ __ ] care
yeah and that's really like the the
biggest storyline in the book and then
in the show it becomes ancillary because
there's all these other storylines
happening like Izzi and the drama
between the Richardson's and it's just
like it's crazy
so overall I thought it was a bad show
based on a bad book but the show made it
worse yeah and the show got worse I
thought that maybe that's why they did
it the way that they did because the
first three episodes they were at least
four pretty good and then I just felt
like each week we got another episode
and it just it just got worse and worse
and worse and I just legitimately forgot
to watch it yeah
um and I could understand that else so
just like gave me a pit and was really
sad I don't know and I couldn't separate
the book from the show and and that's
what I'm realizing now is I actually
don't like when books are turned into
shows our movies I'm realizing because
it just like kind of ruins it for me
because they definitely do take creative
liberties but like so there's a show on
Hulu now called normal people mm-hmm on
a book I just read the book I didn't
like the book that much mostly because
of the way that it was written um and
now I don't really want to watch the
show either cuz I'm like oh you're just
comparing the whole time and then it
just it's weird so I did all this
because I wanted some oh so ultimately I
read little fires everywhere cuz I
wanted the sensation of reading a book
and then having it turn to a show and
what did that feel like and Here I am a
few months later felt bad okay great so
you never have to do it again yeah now I
know okay anything else that you watch
that you want to talk about before we
head over to Deer toasters I don't think
so okay dear toasters our advice segment
if you ever want to write in we always
keep it anonymous
it is dear toasters at gmail.com we'll
talk about anything from quarantine
stuff to wedding stuff whatever you want
here we go
dear toasters I want a new wedding ring
but every time I bring it up it seems to
upset my husband we got engaged fairly
quickly and we're moving across the
country for my job so all the time we
agreed to use at the time we used agreed
to use a family ring from my now
mother-in-law to save money it's pretty
and dainty but nothing I have I would
have picked out there's also a lot of
drama and tension surrounding our
engagement so I'm just not emotionally
attached to it
I'm not allowed to wear my ring at work
and when I can wear it I'm never excited
to put it on my husband often asked why
didn't you wear your ring I tried a
number of times I'm sorry I've tried it
a number of different bands to make it
work for me and it just doesn't any time
I bring up a replacement my husband
shuts down and makes comments about how
I don't care about the ring he got me
but it was free so I'm confused why he
seems to be so attached to it we've been
very happily married for several years
and more in love than ever I want
something special to wear to symbolize
that but I'm afraid if I pushed in a
ring it'll be tainted too I think you
just gotta like ride it out a little
with the ring like I think once you're
married you can talk about an upgrade um
oh they are yeah husband how long have
they been they got engaged she didn't
say but they got engaged like kind of
quickly because they were moving across
the country for her job so they didn't
it was like it was not like a shotgun
wedding but the engagement was was quick
because of all these moving pieces so
she just took this ring for him her
mother-in-law now they've been married
for a while and she wants a new ring I
think that's fair I just think you need
to find like the right occasion to be
receiving whether it's like a 5-year
anniversary or a big birthday 30th 35th
like let your husband know that you love
this ring but you're not like you're
just ready for a new one I don't know
this is really weird I don't know what
to tell you yeah but people upgrade
their rings all the time even if it has
nothing to do even if your ring wasn't
free so you're married one year and then
you're in a different place in your
tenth year and you want something to
signify the 10 years like everything
it's a wait till you have to wait till
ten years yeah I don't know I don't know
how many years this girl's been married
but like five years that could work
that's what I'm saying just make it for
a big milestone because people don't
just like
new engagement rings on a Wednesday um
but I think that that's fine and also
yeah it cuz because it was technically
free it's not like you're wasting money
yeah you haven't spent the money yet so
I just think be be honest and and a
patient yeah but I don't think it's an
unreasonable request no I don't think so
either
I think like you should be happy with
with your aim of course like you should
look down on it and like think of the
wonderful life you build together like
not your mother-in-law if you don't like
her yeah um hey Jackie and Claudia first
off thank you guys so much for taking
the time to read my email nothing crazy
but I need someone to tell me I'm being
crazy and to stop or I need someone to
tell me it's okay and to keep indulging
in this guilty pleasure of mine so am i
I am in a very happy relationship with
my boyfriend of four years we're pretty
solid but I have this guilty pleasure of
making fake instrumentalities and
following my ex-boyfriends on it like
why am I like this does this see does
this mean I'm gonna secretly not over my
exes and I don't realize what do you
guys think no matter how many times I
try and stop obsessing I just can't stop
and I make another account I love
knowing what they're up to I feel like
this isn't normal but I haven't I have
no idea I can't afford a therapist so I
need your eyes his opinion thank you
love a one day or fan one day a day one
or fan sorry
that's so funny I'm gonna go ahead and
say the fact that you follow all of them
and you care about all of them means you
don't care about one or the over the
other this isn't about you being hung up
on one X this is just like I kind of I
get it I don't think it's that alarming
I think if it was just like one person
like the one that got away and you just
like can't move on from it um that would
be a little bit more concerning but you
seem like it's a good attitude about the
whole thing some people just like need
to know like some people stop even when
it's like an enemy of yours or a former
friend you just need to follow them some
people don't like and I don't think
there's anything like really wrong with
it just cuz you're following a former
friend doesn't mean just cuz your like
stalking a former friend doesn't mean
you don't love your your current friends
like you just like have this innate need
to know and I think that that is fine
you are you were the TEC Claudia is the
type of person that like needs to know
what her enemies are up to all the time
like I need to know what everyone is up
to all the time I relate to this so hard
I don't think you're in love with your
ex-boyfriends like I have a think
Instagram account too that I keep up
with like
really ex-boyfriends but just like
people I hate and I totally just like
need to know what they're up to I check
it for [ __ ] times a day like I hear
you I don't think you're crazy it's you
know what information is powerful and I
feel that so I think you're totally fine
and you can keep looking I just I agree
if it were one it would be alarming but
just like you wanting to know what
people from your past are up to whether
or not you were romantically involved to
me is not weird no and you know what I'm
not like Claudia like I don't have a
things and I don't stalk people that I
wouldn't feel good about following but I
still think that this is fine um and I
also feel like a therapist like I don't
know if they were like an older maybe
you need like a contemporary millennial
therapist because if they're because
like we might think that this is
alarming but as a contemporary I really
don't know I don't think it's alarming
at all but and like you that's exactly
what Jackie said like you have the
self-awareness to know like it's kind of
weird but that self-awareness makes it
okay yeah definitely um as long as you
like and this is on you to like decipher
its like if you see like one of your
exes has a new girlfriend as long as
that's not like a punch in the stomach
um and you're just keeping tabs that's
fine and doctors Theodore feminine is
here and he wants you to know that he
completely endorses this doctor Theo
fudge has officially entered the chat
all right third and final dear toasters
it's a little bit long let me get my
I've been like reading not well today
same always Hey ladies
firstly thank you so much for creating
such a wonderful such wonderful content
during this time the students have
really been a bright light during this
pandemic thank you now my issue slash
question I am 36 and I've been with my
33 year old boyfriend for just over two
years we have lived together since last
summer we have a great relationship we
both treat each other well the same
values and we love each other's families
we had a serious relationship talk
before Christmas about our next step
engagement and how it would happen
around summer this year
well now that Q has put everything on
hold he doesn't want to make any plans
especially large financial ones until we
know how this will unfold we're both
lucky enough to still have jobs however
I'm an event planning so working on my
clients weddings all day makes me that
much more aware that my life is on hold
my question is Q aside comic did you
both discuss getting engaged before the
actual proposal
did you give Benin mames a gentle push
or a firm one how do you think I should
approach this with everything going on I
mean it's not like jewelry stores are
even open now I'm trying to stay
positive with everything q related but
I'm impatient and I'm not getting any
younger Thanks
toaster ready from the ring okay so the
cute definitely complicates everything
but to answer your first question how
much of a tip we talk about it what kind
of push was there yes we definitely
talked about it like we each had our own
sort of like timelines of how we thought
things should play out and I think
eventually both of those like he wanted
proposing earlier than he would have and
I wound up getting engaged later than I
might have thought um it definitely
takes like the romance out of it you'd
have to talk about it all the time but
you know what like it we're mature
adults like we need to communicate this
is these are big decisions that we're
making about our futures and like people
should be on the same page sometimes
it's a difference of a few months and I
don't think that is a big deal but when
it's a difference of a few years like
that is something that needs to be
talked through because you guys
obviously have different ideas of your
future and that's important with the Q
though that would technically be the
difference of a few months and I feel
like you can give him that grace period
because yeah people don't want to be
making financial investments at this
time like all weddings are postponed
like you know the girls who got engaged
in 2019 like 2021 is now they're here so
like everyone kind of gets pushed back a
little bit um so I think with Quarantine
it just means like being a little bit
more patient but I feel like you can say
to him like I want to be engaged by the
end of this year and that would be very
fair yeah the the the timeline is like I
just get such anxiety for people like I
was lucky enough to have like the
structure of college where it was like
we knew we were gonna get engaged after
college like that was all that really
needs to be said because like graduation
came and then we were engaged month
later but like wouldn't people have like
jobs and now like with the financial
crisis like it really does add all these
external elements that like make it an
already uncomfortable conversation like
a little bit more uncomfortable and
confusing and I feel for you
Jacky's right like a few months in the
grand scheme of the world is really not
a huge deal I'm sure you're just like
thinking of weddings 24/7 because it's
your job and therefore it's making you
antsy but I think the quarantine
delaying you're engaged
like is okay yeah just like figure out
what you can live with let your partner
know and if that's what like if they
wouldn't make you happy like you they'll
they'll get to step in and do and do
that you know and I feel like now
quarantine is we're on the tail end of
like hardcore quarantine so you wanted
to be engaged by summer maybe it'll
happen in the fall and and that is okay
yeah and you know what if you get
engaged now like you'll probably have to
get engaged in your apartment so maybe
just wait a few months yeah or like over
zoom yeah um also I forget what I was
gonna say oh the most important thing
though is that you still want to marry
this person and I think being in
quarantine like gives you that absolute
certainty or not about where you stand
so you know what if you are certain that
you want to marry this person like it
will happen and that's the most
important thing to know right now and
you have that certainty preach well that
was it good questions yeah if you guys
want to write in ever the email is dear
toasters at gmail.com we always keep it
anonymous so if you want to get weird
frisky whatever we don't mind so dear
testers at gmail.com anything else you
want to say Jackson where we are about
the show just happy birthday to our
sister this natural counsellor snitch um
if you're watching like make sure to
wish our happy birthday uh we love you
so much counselor snitch I know you're
not watching so I'll just take to
Instagram to post but or you can listen
to the snatchler new episode of the
sanctuary's up today with Andy Grammer
because he was a guest judge on listen
to your heart so there's a side note a
new episode of Marco Joseph's podcast
with Melissa Gorga which is gonna be so
good I have to listen to it so much
premium content by the time we are back
here tomorrow the redheads episode will
be up so make sure you're subscribed
make sure reading the books if you are
bored in the queue and your in the
keyboard become a redhead because we
have so much content for you like you
could spend a whole week reading more
than like two weeks reading all the
books with us any type of episodes and
having a grand ol time amen to that
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast millennium Morning
Show we go live Monday through Friday
10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on YouTube so if
you're watching us on YouTube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcast
he founds that Spotify iTunes stitcher
public radio I already owe cashbox all
the places to wherever you listen to
podcast finest money doesn't leave a
five-star review about a beautiful
setting and smart we are we love you
guys and we will see you tomorrow bye